the post office expects more packages
this year than previous years as more
and more families choose to celebrate
with each other
virtually post office leaders say your
best bet is to make sure your packages
arrive on time is to mail early
here are some important dates to
remember for military or family members
in correctional facilities
packages need to be in the mail by
december 11th for priority mail
it's december 19th and for priority mail
express december 23rd there are also
options if you don't want to stand in
line at the post office
another tool that we did a lot of
additional preparation to is the click
and ship
feature that can be found on usps.com
and with that being used they can
generate their mailing label
they can weigh their packages and get
the right postage and so then all they
would have to do is go to a retail
location drop the package off or they
can schedule a package pick
up the post office branches across
nevada says they are well staffed to
handle the influx of packages
and they do not anticipate any delays